[Music]
this is your Tech news briefing for
Tuesday April 11th I'm Zoe Thomas for
The Wall Street Journal
caught an Uber ride in San Francisco
last September with a driver named Dave
K you may have actually been shuttled
around by the ride hailing company's CEO
Dara khosra Shahi it was the latest move
by cosmasharhi to reinvent Uber since
taking the Helm of the company five
years ago our ride hail and food
delivery reporter Preeti Karana is with
us to discuss what he learned hi pratika
thanks for joining us thanks Zoe great
to be here so let's talk about this
experiment by Uber's CEO why did he
decide to do this to become a driver
temporarily and a food deliverer it all
started because uh both Uber and Lyft
were struggling with a year's Long
driver shortage after the US reopened
from pandemic lockdowns and drivers just
one coming back and so initially Uber
tried to attract them with bonuses and
money and some of them came back but not
as many as the company had hoped so that
was really a moment of Reckoning where
Uber said okay we're coming out of the
pandemic and drivers have a lot more
options now you know grocery food
delivery services had taken off and it
was a wake-up moment where Uber realized
all right we actually have to become a
better employer so to speak a better app
for drivers to drive if we want them to
come back you spoke with Dara what was
he like as a driver so the CEO of uber
gets anxious the nights before he has to
drive because right now he is a perfect
five-star driver and he worries that any
small thing could mean that his rating
could dip just the next day so one
instance that I found particularly
entertaining is Uber's Network got
hacked late last year and it was a big
deal Dara was actually driving a
customer to the airport at the time that
happened and he had to ignore frantic
calls from his chief legal officer he
just didn't want to take a call while he
was in the car with a writer there are
some other things he does just to seem
polite and just to seem like a helpful
driver one is he keeps charging cables
both for Apple and Android users he
tries to entertain writers with music he
has tons of Spotify playlists Taylor
Swift is on that playlist a DJ called
Flume so I found those details quite
interesting because for me they humanize
the Driving Experience one of the other
things he ran into is just rude writers
which a lot of drivers unfortunately
have to contend with how similar was his
experience to what a regular driver
would have because I think a lot of us
have seen these you know the boss comes
in and takes on you know a different job
for a while it never seems quite the
same so what was his experience like I
mean obviously he didn't need the money
so that is I think one of the biggest
differentials what he did run into is
some of driver's biggest complaints and
when he did that's when he realized oh
drivers are actually right we gotta go
in and actually fix some of these things
so one of the things was when he started
delivering food in the summer of 2021 he
hopped onto an electric bike and the
sign up process itself was what he
called pretty clunky Uber had a
different signup process for whether he
wanted to Ferry people versus whether
you wanted to deliver food and that's
when the CEO realized hey we have a food
delivery business why aren't we
leveraging this pool of workers better
let's just create a single sign-up
process and so people could you know
more seamlessly toggle between both
something else that he ran into was this
problem of tibeting which a lot of
delivery drivers have been complaining
about people attract drivers they want
to get matched quickly to a driver
because they want their food to get to
them quicker so they put in big tips but
once the food gets there they lower the
tip so the CEO of uber got debated and
Uber's still trying to figure out a
solution to that problem but one of the
things it started doing was it started
taking away customers ability in some
markets to lower tips after their food
got to them but they found out okay that
is actually reducing overall tipping on
the app because people didn't want to be
stuck with big tips beforehand you know
suppose you get the wrong order or
suppose your food never gets to you they
didn't want to be stuck giving a 25
percent tip so that was his experience
as a food deliverer what was his
experience like as a driver so in
September last year after five years of
leading Uber you know the CEO starts
driving an Uber and very immediately he
runs into again summer driver's biggest
complaints one of them was this
inability for drivers to see expected
earnings and where that ride is going to
take you beforehand so drivers could see
destinations up front but only those
drivers with high trip acceptance rates
so Dara starts rejecting trips and
immediately he's punished by the app and
the app takes away his ability to see
destinations up front because his trip
acceptance rate dips so Uber had already
been testing this in certain markets
where it had taken away this restriction
it it had let all drivers see
destinations up front but that market
did not include San Francisco when Dara
was driving so his experience basically
was so frustrating that he said look we
gotta remove this restriction across all
markets how are drivers reacting to
these changes the drivers that I spoke
to definitely recognized that everything
from Uber's maps to its safety tools are
much better than its competitor lift but
that said there are many points that
remain contentious for one drivers one
better pay they want more transparency
over how fares are divided so all in all
drivers seem to agree that okay this is
a good start but you know there's still
a long way to go before the company can
truly call itself driver friendly so
what is this going to mean for the
company's future you know having drivers
that actually like driving on the app is
is a big plus because now Uber's you
know not the only company on the Block
for Gig work there are so many other
services that boom you know e-commerce
delivery services during the pandemic so
having a loyal driver base definitely
makes it more competitive so if it does
have that supply of drivers that
definitely sets it up to expand more
quickly into new categories alright that
was our ride hail and food delivery
reporter Preeti garada thanks for
joining us pritika thanks Zoe and that's
it for today's Tech news briefing for
more Tech stories head over to our
website
wsj.com I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall
Street Journal thanks for listening
[Music]